[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
welcome walter welcome martin
are you doing well yes
me too
before we begin
we've mentioned in a previous whatsapp a
while back that we were doing a
series on hebrews yes and i think it's
important that we let the viewers know
it's already started
previous friday and we encourage you to
go and have a look at
the series that will be airing every
friday
at six o'clock south african time
particularly in a time when the world is
rapidly moving
into a system of apostasy which is
incomprehensible
and where jesus christ is being
marginalized more and more
i think it's essential in this time
that we put an emphasis
on the exact position
of the redeemer
jesus christ
and that is why we have decided to do a
study on the book of hebrews yeah thank
you very much for that study and we we
thank god for allowing you to do it
and with that let's put jesus first in
this discussion
because it will be important to have him
here with us i do wouldn't want to be
without him now
our heavenly father we have such an
important discussion to do
and we cannot do this without you so we
ask that you please enlighten our minds
with the holy spirit
and be present here
to guide our
thoughts and discussion in jesus name
amen
martin as we said just now when we spoke
about the book of hebrews
the world has managed to put a great
gulf
between
truth
and what the world
presents as truth
and it has succeeded in ridiculing the
word of god to such an extent
that it is
regarded as a storybook of allegories
rather than historic
realities
now you know when
the world
and the bible come into conflict
it seems to me that the world wants to
run with the science
but we've spoken about science falsely
so-called before right correct yeah now
just because the world says something
and just because eminent scientists say
something doesn't mean that it is so
because everything is wrapped up in
theories
and a theory
is not a fact no all right we've
discussed this many times
no matter
how you look at it
the world of science is not going to be
in harmony with the book of genesis
and there's a decision to be made
do we believe what the bible says or
don't we
now not only the bible when we come to
the spirit of prophecy how far will we
go yeah
so we've titled this one the church in
crisis
questions on the state of things
so
basically what we're going to do is
we're going to look at some questions
and then we'll try and answer those
questions
and we will see
that many of the questions bring us into
direct conflict
with the world view
and unfortunately the bible says that
even the elect will be deceived yeah so
if we do not cling
to the truths that have been revealed
in the word of god and the testimony of
jesus christ
then we can be led to compromises
or even to a total rejection of the
bible and the spirit of prophecy it's so
dangerous because if you decide
that oh not decide the bible says like
we've mentioned before
the word is truth yes so then it means
the whole word is truth yes there's
nothing there's no lie in there
so now you have to put your trust
completely
from genesis 1 until revelation 22
correct
and here's another important point when
the world starts ridiculing
what the word of god says
on whatever issue
whether it is the historic origin
whether it is the historic
history of the unfolding of the events
whatever topic whether it is health
whether it is salvation
when the world starts ridiculing
and the church
accepts some of the premises of the
world
that's when we have a crisis correct in
the church so shall we
ask some questions yes let's so
basically this is this is a whole
talk on questions right correct it's not
a normal questions and answer like not
usually no this is
these are questions
so martin let us start gently
and ask the first question and then
we'll build up as we
go along
so the first question is are we involved
in a battle between good and evil truth
and error
without a question
so there is no doubt that we are
involved in a battle between good and
evil
the bible describes such a battle right
yeah
and it gives us the origin of this
battle
and there are many that even deny the
very existence of
the
other realm the realm of evil the devil
now i've been involved in occultism in
my life
and so i know that this is a reality
strange
even when i was an atheist
i was involved in the occult realm
that's strange because
they actually you actually deny any
sports um form of it yes but you're
involved in it correct so
this is an absolute oxymoron but this is
the way it is
so there is a battle between good and
evil
and truth and error right
if we go to genesis chapter 3 verse 6 we
read and when the woman saw that the
tree was good for food
and that it was pleasant to the eyes and
a tree to be desired to make one wise
she took off the fruit thereof and did
eat and gave also unto her husband with
her and he did eat
so number one we see here that she
saw that the tree was good for food even
though it had been declared an evil
it was not the fruit that was bad it was
the consequences of the disbelief in
what god had said that was bad right
so if you do not believe god's word you
question it
you don't only question it you put it to
the test and go against it
then
you become wise in your own eyes
and she partook and her husband partook
and the rest is history right correct
so that's the origin
so the basic origin is distrust in the
word of god
that's where it all starts that's where
it starts
genesis chapter 4 verse 8 and cain
talked with abel his brother and it came
to pass when they were in the field
that cain rose up against abel his
brother and slew him
i put that verse in there
because this is the consequence
right that's exactly what happens so
how
heavy is this conflict between good and
evil
to the point of death correct
that's ex that's the outcome that's the
outcome
so these two parties
those that stand for truth
and those that imbibe error
will be there to the close of time
now the trouble is
when there's doubt
about what god has said
creeps even into the church
then the conflict doesn't only rage
between the church and the world but the
conflict rages within the church
do we see that
yes right unfortunately that's what's
happening or some people may pay lip
service to the truth
but deny it in their actions
right that's why you
know them by their fruits okay
so
no matter what we do we will not be able
to avoid
conflict no
and in the end this conflict
rages in the world this conflict rages
in the church
and it brings us to a position
where each one individually has to make
a choice
and if you stand for the one
you will be
lambasted by your brother yeah
that's a promise that's the way it is
right it's a very sad state of affairs
all right having established that
let's ask another question
if evil exists today
where according to the scriptures will
it manifest itself
and do the scriptures warn against
specific
organizations
where it might manifest itself yes so
the bible is full of warnings and it
also gives you details all right so it
has historic warnings for the
the end time people of god it has
prophetic warnings for the end time
people of god and everything in between
this right
so the scriptures will tell us
where we can find evil
and the scriptures will warn us against
specific organizations
[Music]
that are the harborers
the custodians as it were
of evil correct
now if we believe the scriptures
then even though the facade
of these organizations might look good
you will have to look behind the scenes
because scripture has revealed them as
evil
and then you will find the evil
correct that's 100 because
like you just said sometimes it looks
like and even the name of the
organization
portrays it to be godly yes but if the
bible already told you
there's something
amiss yes you have to go
and look deeper okay so
we've established
there is a battle between good and evil
that
we can find evil in the world and the
bible has given us a definition of what
unrighteousness is and where we will
find it
and we can therefore discern where this
battle will range and be forewarned
okay
let's have a look at that so can we say
that where sin
the transgression of the law abounds
there we will find evil
yes
right because the bible says sin is the
transgression of the law
so when you have
individuals or organizations that
blatantly trample on the law of god
we may know that that is where evil
abounds
now martin
on how many of the laws do they need to
trample in order for us to be warned
that there is evil involved
only one
because if you transgress one
you transgress them all right
so
it should be possible to discern
whether an organization or an individual
is in harmony with the word of god yes
or no right yes definitely because the
bible gives you the guideline
okay
so wherever the transgression of the law
abounds
even if it is the transgression of one
of the laws
then we might know that there is evil
involved right
now what if the laws
even of the land protect the evil
it doesn't make it right
then it just
encourages the evil right
all right
the bible also warns against the beast
and against the image of the beast and
against the dragon as particular
organizational structures that will be
involved
in the transgression of god's law
to such a point that the bible warns
against them
revelation chapter 16 verse 13 says
and i saw three unclean spirits like
frogs
came out of the mouth of the dragon
and out of the mouth of the beast
and out of the mouth of the false
prophet
now martin i don't think it is for
nothing
that the bible identifies the three
components of babylon here
now who's the dragon the dragon is the
devil he's satan right
so does the dragon speak through
organizations
that are affiliated with the beast and
the false prophet
yes
so can we find an occult agenda
associated with the beast and the false
prophet yep
now martin
if you deny that there is an occult
agenda attached to the beast
and attached or associated with the
false prophet
then you are denying the occult
connection
to the devil himself yes you're denying
the truth all right
now
if you're going to deceive humanity
then you have to put a fair face
in front right of course because
you have to get the attention away okay
so martin can we expect
that the beast
which we know is catholicism
will put a fair front
towards the world absolutely and can we
expect that the false prophet that does
his bidding and speaks on his behalf
will have a fair front
a lamb-like front
right
but is it possible that both of them
could be associated with the dragon i
don't think it's evenly possible
it has to be like that all right can i
ask another question seeing that we're
in the question mode
which of the three
will be
in secret
the dragon
the dragon will operate in secret but he
will be very powerfully associated with
the beast and with the false prophet
because they are speaking out of one
mouth yes because the beast and the
false prophet has a face of christianity
correct the dragon is working in secret
behind them he's working in secret
behind the scenes okay
now martin is it also possible you think
that if you expose this dragon component
as associated with the beast and the
false prophet that people will shout
conspiracy
if possible right yes
all right so we've been warned about
these organizations the beast
organization
the image of the beast organization
and the dragon organization
now
do we find them that is the next
question
and is the church even deceived
when it comes to
the activities of these components and
how they are interconnected
that's why the bible warns that even the
elect
can be deceived
that brings us to the third question
if good exists
then where will we find it
where the law is being kept
where the truth abounds
okay so obviously the opposite of evil
right yes
so can we say that we will find it
wherever god's word is honored and the
law obeyed
exactly how much of the law
all of the law all of the law
isaiah 8 20 to the law
and to the testimony
if they speak not according to this word
it is because there is no
light in them
the law there's the torah it's the bible
the testimony is what the prophets have
testified
so if it's not in harmony with scripture
then there's no light right
let's see if we can find the same thing
in in the new testament revelation 1 9 i
john
who also am your brother and a companion
in tribulation
and in the kingdom and patience of jesus
christ was in the isle
that is called patmos
why for two reasons
for the word of god
which is the law yes and
for the testimony of jesus christ
so he believed everything
that the scripture said
so you've got the old testament
and the new testament testifying to the
same thing all right so we have this
contrast in the bible we know that there
is evil
and that there's a conflict between good
and evil symbolized by cain and abel
we know that there are organizations
that will have a front
of christianity
and seem to be in support of the word of
god in fact make a big show of being in
in harmony with the word of god but they
violate all the principles and they are
in league with the dragon
so this is a very important issue we
need to understand this is a conflicting
issue like we saw in the beginning
correct eventually it will lead to death
yes
so that brings us to the fourth question
what is the difference between
of the world
and
in the world
because this is something that jesus
talks about
you know in a very very succinct way
and he makes a very distinct difference
so we have to be able to discern who is
of the world
and
in the world but not necessarily of the
world right
let's look at that and see if we can
discern something
if we were of the world says john 15
verse 19
if you were of the world
the world would love his own
but because you are not of the world but
i have chosen you out of the world
therefore the world
hateth you
now that's a very interesting
statement
so if you want to determine who is of
the world
and who is in the world but not
necessarily of the world
could we say
that if the world loves you and raves
about you then you're probably in
trouble
that's exactly our yes all right
so if you look at the great heroes in
the world the great stars of the world
the popular people in the world
the mega
uh rich in the world
that could be a problem right i think it
can even go further than that
doesn't it can go into his institutions
even christian institutions if the world
loves you but if you meet in a little
dungeon somewhere you you might be on
the right side right
okay let's see if we can find some more
information john 17 verse 14.
i have given them thy word
and the world has hated them
because they are not of the world even
as i am not of the world well here's
another very interesting point
i've given them thy word
that is the law and the testimony
and if you have them
and you live according to them what will
be the consequence the world will hate
you the world will hate you
isn't that strange martin
do you think that this could even happen
within the church yes
it can be also that you want popularity
with the world so
you do certain things to be accepted but
unfortunately you don't realize that you
are
going the wrong way okay
so
this is this is very interesting
let's have a look another verse john 17
15 and i pray not that thou should take
them out of the world
but that thou should keep them from the
evil
so we know there's evil
we know it's raging
we know that there are organizations
which are defined as being run by
unclean spirits
that have front organizations and secret
operations of which
nobody wants to hear
but they are basically fighting against
god's word and against god's law
and if you are for god's word and for
god's law then the world will hate you
it's a given that's it
right
okay
that brings us to the fifth question
where and with whom
do the kings of the world stand in this
conflict
also with the dragon
okay
and with the beast and with the beast
and with a false prophet now martin
this is a very serious serious question
because you know
the kings of the world
have been given authority
but their authority
is
restricted
their authority may not
encroach
upon authority over the word of god
right yes
so when it comes to obeying the kings of
the world
the bible makes it very clear that it is
only in so far as they do not curtail
you when it comes to obedience to god
right yes
but the bible is also very clear as to
where the kings of the world stand in
this conflict so
let's just make sure of that
revelation 17 verse 1
and there came one of the seven angels
which had the seven vials and talked
with me saying unto me come heather
i will show unto thee the judgment of
the great
that sitteth upon many waters in other
words
that apostate church that sits on many
nations
with whom
the kings of the earth have committed
fornication
that's pretty clear that's it so on
whose side are the kings of the world on
the side of the word of god and the
testimony or on the side of
the the beast the beast
okay
and the inhabitants of the earth have
been made drunk with the wine of a
fornication
so it seems to me that the inhabitants
of the earth are victims here
because they've been made drunk by false
doctrines
of her apostasy which she peddles
as faithfulness that's it right
now we showed in the last one
that the pope clearly said you may
preach jesus
but you may not keep the truth yeah
and if you want to keep the commandments
then you are not with jesus well what
jesus does he have because jesus said
if you love me keep my commandments
it's amazing it's amazing right it is
amazing
but the bible is very clear that the
kings of the earth are not on the right
side of this conflict they're on the
wrong side
so
when i look at what the kings of the
earth commission
should i be
very
careful and hesitant before i go along
with him
definitely you have to be so on your
guard
with god's help because like we
mentioned earlier
the dragon will be sitting behind this
in secret surrender unto caesar what is
due unto him but unto god what is due
unto him and if the two are in conflict
if they prevent you from doing what is
due unto god then you have to choose god
it is expedient right that we should
obey god rather than man the bible is
very clear on that issue
and the kings of the world are
definitely according to scripture not on
the right side of the conflict
revelation 13 verse 3 says and i saw one
of the heads
as it were wounded to death and his
deadly wound was healed and all the
world wandered after the beast it seems
to me
that the conflict is loaded
fortified on one side of the conflict
that's it
because that word all is quite
encapsulating
that's it's a very serious word
so i think we've come to the conclusion
that the kings of the world
are on the wrong side of the issue
that we have to be very careful
when we look at decrees and laws
emanating from the kings of the world
and we also have to look at the world
and say
there is a major problem here yes and
you have to say i don't want to be off
the world
good that brings us
to
another question and now we're getting
into
dangerous territory again
is this a never-ending conflict or has
god set a time limit
to the rule of sin
in the bible and the spirit of prophecy
he has shown us that there is a time
limit there will be a judgment
and it will come and it will not tarry
the bible is clear on that
and the spirit of prophecy says the same
thing
a time which god has fixed that's it
right
so if we study the word and we study the
testimony
we should be able to get some idea
as to what this time frame is
and i know that we are on dangerous
ground here
because this seems to be quite a bone of
contention because science
is in serious conflict
with the word and the testimony when it
comes to the issue of time it's actually
interesting
the very
first chapter of the bible
already starts conflict correct
because if you don't trust the first
chapter of the bible you know how can
you trust the rest i wonder i also am so
surprised that the manuscripts which
roman catholicism used to substantiate
modern translations they don't even
contain
the first chapters of of genesis and
they don't even contain the book of
revelation they don't have the beginning
nor have they end they have nothing
about the alpha and omega therefore
and so they glean the rest from a
handful of unkills and documents which
they dig up out of desert sand
to substantiate their view right if the
bible says to the law and to the
testimony and that constitutes the word
it has it's of utmost important that
it's the correct word correct absolutely
all right so
it's not an ever
never-ending conflict
otherwise you know
existence would be an eternal misery
it's going to come to an end now what is
the time limit that god has said
let's read it
this comes from adventist home and it
reads
the great plan of redemption results in
fully bringing back the world into god's
favor
all that was lost
by sin is restored
not only man but the earth is redeemed
to be the eternal abode of the obedient
for 6 000 years satan has struggled to
maintain possession of the earth
now god's original purpose in its
creation is accomplished the saints of
the most high shall take the kingdom and
possess the kingdom forever even forever
and ever
now this statement will cause
controversy in the world
it's not in harmony with the science
that the world propagates
and it seems to create consternation in
the church as well
because there are people that will say
six thousand years that must be
allegorical
it cannot be a fixed number in fact this
here this statement refers to
a time after the millennium and it
refers to the time that
satan has to war against god's
government yes and that total time is 6
000 years according to the statement yes
because otherwise if it was an allegory
it would have said for thousands of
years correct so now
does the church still believe this
martin
unfortunately no
and the majority don't the majority
don't believe it so is there even a war
raging
between what the testimonies say in this
particular instance
and how the church in many instances
wishes to interpret it yes
now you know what i find it interesting
that many even within the church
have no qualm
with saying in six days the lord created
but if you want to put that little word
in that sentence which says literal
in six literal days
god created
then there's a war yeah
because they wanted to be allegorical
they wanted to be
of the world of the world
but this
is pretty definitive yes
now we've spoken about it before and
there was quite a bit of consternation
but there is a time frame
which god has fixed
now we also said that god
can lengthen the days or can shorten the
day so let's just reiterate that again
but there is a time frame
and that time frame is in harmony with
the scriptures definitely
now it's also interesting that it's only
in harmony with the scriptures
if you use
the right manuscripts like the masoretic
text once you start using manuscripts
like the alex for example
then there is
no harmony
in terms of the ages then that must
conclude that if you go to the word of
god you have to go to the right
manuscripts
and
can we also conclude that the word and
the testimony must be in harmony with
each other oh definitely
all right so let's not belabor the point
any further
except to say that if you want to
believe
even end up on the isle of patmos for
the word of god and the testimony then
you could get into trouble here right
well the bible says it will happen
i find it interesting
i come from the world where i believed
in billions of years right and i was an
evolutionist as everybody at nausea
knows now already
and
the more i've studied it the more i've
come to the conclusion
that i can trust the word of god
and i've had discussions with
some of our own
geologists within the church
and they will not
many of them
some of them will but many of them won't
accept 6 000 jews it find i find it
strange that they're happy to maybe
accept ten thousand thousand
why not six
and some of them are happy to accept a
hundred thousand
and some of them are just way off the
bat and believe in billions of years
and
that is quite a large proportion that
actually believes what the world has
said
so
to the law and to the testimony if they
speak not according to this word they
have no light in them so i must conclude
from that statement that there are many
in the church that on this issue have no
light in them
yes
i actually
said to one you know if you believe in
ten thousand
you will be ridiculed by the world yeah
and if you believe in ten thousand
you're not in harmony with the word or
the spirit of prophecy either right
you're not in harmony with the testimony
or the word
you're sitting between two chairs
so if you're going to make a fool of
yourself for god then at least go and
sit on the chair
that he recommends right yep
all right so this is a very interesting
point and
it's very important martin let me tell
you why
because if you believe that it's not
that has been allocated
if you believe it's ten thousand
then
can you postpone the coming of christ
indefinitely indefinitely
you can make it ten and a half thousand
you can make it eleven and you can work
your way up through to the hundred
thousand and eventually to the millions
if you want to right yeah okay
but if you really believe this
and you do a little calculation which we
won't do now
then how close are we to the coming of
christ
exactly as close as he said it would be
thank you for that answer i think that
is
pretty good let's leave it at that so
let's not quite leave it at that let's
ask another question
if you believe that
if you really believe it
what will that mean in terms of
complacency about the coming of christ
you won't be sitting and
not doing anything you will believe that
the time is imminent right
and do you think that
you might look at events current events
in the light of a very soon coming of
christ you will be
scrutinizing the signs you must
scrutinize because you know
that the time is
short
how short
very sorry even at the door even at the
door so can you see why this is an
important point
but but let's leave it at that let's not
belabor it anymore just throw it out
there and think about it
shall we ask another question yes
question number seven
if this is so
and there is a time limit
then where are we in the stream of time
we've actually
answered it right
then we must be at the door
that must mean that the prophetic events
unfolding before our eyes
must be associated with the time frame
involved
nothing that happens
now
is by chance
and separated from anything else correct
so
if you believe
the bible and the spirit of prophecy on
this point
and you do not want to allegorize it
then you will have your antenna eyes
upright
and absorbing every bit of information
and saying we have to warn the world the
time is at hand
if we read a statement in the book child
guidance it says we cannot afford to
live with no reference to the day of
judgment
for thou long delayed it is now near
even at the door and hasten us greatly
the trumpet of the archangel will soon
startle the living and wake the dead
this must be our attitude
and
unfortunately
i don't see this attitude within our
ranks and therefore
we have titled this presentation a
crisis
in the church correct
all right martin
questions can be
very unnerving right
but questions
let you think for yourself that's what
we have to do we have to ask questions
because if you just put statements out
there then it's people saying you said
it yes so you know in any teaching
profession and i've been in the teaching
profession
for most of my life
uh
just providing information doesn't
create thinking people
asking the questions and trying to get
the answers
makes thinking people that's it
so let's ask another question question
number eight
can we thus expect the fulfillment of
unfulfilled prophecy to be imminent
the bible says so
it has to happen so people that say that
what is happening in the world now is
just a glitch on the horizon
and it will pass by and will go back to
normal
don't believe
the prophetic time frame
no right
they don't know they don't believe it
or at least i must assume they don't
believe it or they allegorize it away
but it doesn't believe specifically what
the word and the testimony says on the
issue
and just another thing on this that you
mentioned earlier normal going back to
normal if you go back a hundred and
fifty years
normal was different then than it was
that we used to have before this whole
episode correct we are living in a new
normal who says that that was normal
three years ago
all right it's just normal for your time
frame so
you can't go back to something if
prophecy is keeping on fulfilling
so our line of thought will then have to
answer this question
so we can expect unfulfilled prophecy to
be imminently
fulfilled right
so will that make you look at the news
and at the events in a different light
it has to will you war against it or
will you say
brothers and sisters
this is a very serious issue
time's up
the days in which we live are solemn and
important
the spirit of god is gradually but
surely being withdrawn from the earth
anybody
who watches the news can see that
plagues and judgments already falling
upon the despisers of the grace of god
the calamities by land and sea the
unsettled state of society the alarms of
war are pretentious
they forecast approaching events of the
greatest magnitudes
the agencies of evil are combining their
forces
and consolidating
they are strengthening for the last
great crisis great changes are soon to
take place in our world and the final
movements will be rapid ones
what do you do with that
if you
don't believe in the prophetic
fulfillment
then you have excuses or
explanations for all of this happening
okay
but we've highlighted a certain section
here
the agencies of evil
we've already determined
where the evil is right because the
bible tells us
are combining their forces
now we know that babylon consists of
three components
and the agencies of evil are combining
their forces
that means that the dragon component the
beast component and the false prophet
component behind the scenes are
combining their forces why
and they are consolidating
why are they doing it they're
strengthening for the last great crisis
that's it
that's what they're doing right
and then we'll see great changes
there will be a new normal right yes and
the final movements will be rapid ones
because we are operating in a time frame
which tells us there's not much time to
do this right
have great changes taken place in the
world as of late
stupendous changes have we seen
rapid movements
very rapid movements
and we've seen them on a universal scale
and that's always a very important clue
have we seen flip-flopping saying this
a few months ago changing your mind at
the end correct in these consolidated
forces
absolutely all right let's have a look
at this because this is another big bone
of contention even within
the church
so our next question number nine
how are the agencies of evil combining
their forces and consolidating and
strengthening themselves for the last
great crisis isn't that something we
should ask definitely because
you want to know
but we've been told where they're going
to operate right yes so we must know
and if you do this then what are you
likely to be called
a conspiracy theorist correct which we
have seen is a heretic right
all right
let's see how they will do this this
comes from letter 114 from 1903 satan
uses the influence of mind on mind
cast out of heaven satan set up his
kingdom in this world and ever since he
has been untiringly striving to seduce
human beings
from their allegiance to god
he uses the same power that he used in
heaven the influence of mind on mind
so will there be
indoctrination
definitely
men become tempters of their fellow men
the strong corrupting sentiments of
satan are cherished and they exert a
masterly compelling power under the
influence of these sentiments
men bind up with one another in
confederacies
in trade unions
and in secret societies
there are at work in the world agencies
that god will not much longer tolerate
all right so now we know how
they will set up the secret alliance
they bind themselves up into confederacy
trade unions
and secret societies right
now
when i started lecturing on secret
societies
i received tremendous backlash
largely from within our own ranks
and from the leaders within our own
ranks
this is nothing to do with the message
they told me
and i i should refrain from speaking
about trade unions or secret societies
this is conspiracy theory
but it is part of the testimony yes and
it is part of the bible because azia
clearly warns against the confederacy
and the testimonies link it to the
secret societies
so in many of the cases when i was told
to refrain from speaking on these issues
i would show those verses and say now
who must i obey
all right martin so let us show
how
celebrities are being used
and people are being used to influence
mind upon mine correct all right
you're gone i'm going back home to see
my mom
hey
check this out
we're getting immunity
[Music]
if enough of us do our part by getting
vaccinated
that ripple
can become a wave
my name is elton john
beautiful cut there
the more people in society that get
vaccinated the more chance there is of
eradicating the national covid pandemic
i've just had a vaccine for kovid
it didn't hurt
i want to go back to work and i want to
be able to move around to visit with
michelle's mom the hugger and
see her on her birthday i'll be seeing
you
[Music]
i'll be looking at them all
and i'll be seeing you
find out when you can arm yourself and
book your vaccination
look at some numbers
bts brings 3.6 billion dollars into
south korea every year
through concerts licensing merchandise
they also attract eight hundred thousand
tourists every year that's around seven
percent of all arrivals imagine their
pull
even the united nations is not immune
apparently they requested president moon
to bring bts along the u.n did they said
the band would represent global youth
it's becoming a common request for the
president everywhere he goes
they want him to bring bts along
in fact the band has visited the un
before in 2018
the leader spoke at unicef
last year they sent a pre-recorded
message they asked young people to
overcome the challenges of the pandemic
and pursue their dreams
this year they'll return again not as
guests but a special diplomatic envoys
it's a soft power coup for saudi for
south korea
bts and their fans can change the pulse
of the internet they even manage to be
chinese state media and that's no easy
task
i'll tell you what happened last year
bts paid a tribute to american soldiers
of the korean war the chinese press was
livid how dare they not mention the
chinese soldiers global times punched
out opeds they slammed bts
for its quote-unquote one-sided attitude
all the outrage lasted two days bts fans
flooded social media with hashtags and
tweets global times was outgunned they
started deleting articles from their
website bts one global times zero
the point is celebrities can be great
diplomatic tools they have visibility
they have massive following and people
listen when they speak
something that normal diplomats find
hard to achieve
it's also a big win for the united
nations put bts on and more kids will be
interested they don't want to hear joe
biden talk about climate change i'm
being honest they would much rather hear
bts talk about it
uh the reason why we showed that is to
show the influence of mind upon mind
right correct one of the tools in his
toolbox
here's a statement from darkness before
dawn
political corruption is destroying love
of justice and regard for truth
and even in free america rulers and
legislators in order to secure public
favor will yield to the popular demand
for a law
enforcing sunday observance liberty of
conscience
which has cost so greater sacrifice will
no longer be respected
in the soon coming conflict we shall see
exemplified the prophet's words
the dragon was wrath with the woman and
went to make war with the remnant of her
seed
which keep the commandments of god and
have the testimony of jesus christ
if you look at these things in the
prophetic light
then
you are actually compelled
to put them into the prophetic sequence
that's it you cannot do any other if you
do so there will always be those that
shout yes
conspiracy right
i mean if we just take that bts video
that we've just watched
the chinese news media
gave in to the popular demand
of the supporters of bts and took off
their things so it's happening
you can see this happening in the world
this is the influence of mind upon mind
so it's not only the popular people in
the world
but the beast power
through his representative is also
using the power of mind upon mine and
the whole world wandered after him right
gracias
[Music]
family
it's interesting that all of these great
celebrities
that according
to the bible and the spirit of prophecy
are not on the right side when it comes
to
adhering to the commandments of god and
the testimony of jesus right
they seem to be
free from many of the rules and
regulations that apply to others and
they even mock about it
let's have a look at that
the la county department of health is
responding after seth rogen called out
the primetime emmy awards for not
abiding by covet health and safety
protocols let me start by saying there
is way too many of us in this little
room
what are we doing
they said this was outdoors
it's not
they lied to us
we're in a hermetically sealed tent
right now
i would not have come to this
why is there a roof i went from wiping
my groceries to having paul bettany
sneeze in my face so
that's a big week
yeah it's interesting if you
like you mentioned
certain rules only
apply to certain people
so
just to come back to
the video that we showed
of the pope
if the beast is speaking in a certain
manner
and the world wanders after it then we
should be very careful shouldn't we
just something that i
continually see the bible warns against
so modern when it comes to these
confederacies of evil that are combining
their forces
let's just read another statement
and this one comes from manuscripts 139
all need wisdom
carefully to search out the mystery of
iniquity that figures so largely in the
winding up of this earth's history
if you do this
you can get into big trouble
even within the ranks of the church
god's presentation of the detestable
works of the inhabitants of the ruling
powers of the world who bind themselves
into secret societies and confederacies
not honoring the law of god
should enable the people who have the
light of truth to keep clear of these
evils
that's pretty straightforward yes it
should help you to see this it shouldn't
be ostracized it shouldn't be demonized
you should look at it in fact you have
an instruction to look at it right
more and more will all false
religionists of the world manifest their
evil doings
for there are but two parties those who
keep the commandments of god and those
who war against god's holy law
only two parties
so when the ruling powers
that are working together with the beast
and the false prophet
use the celebrities of the world
to further an agenda
they are working in confederacy that's
it
there's no there's no doubt about it
genesis 6 5 and god saw that the
wickedness of man was great in the earth
and that every imagination of the
thoughts of his hearts were only evil
continually this is the situation in the
world yes
now i have been told on many occasions
not to speak about secret societies
because they have nothing to do with our
present situation
and i've been told
that this is conspiracy and i must stay
out of it
and i said this is not a conspiracy this
is a fact
these people are involved the kings of
the world
the celebrities of the world and the
religious leaders of the world are
involved in secret societies such as
freemasonry and the occult
whether we like it or not yes
i've been told categorically by
high-ranking officials within our own
organization that this is not the case
it is pure conjecture it's conspiracy
well i don't know how blind some people
can actually be but
just for clarity we'll show a video
just to show how associated these people
are and if you want to put them all in
the waste paper basket and say
this doesn't exist
then you are like an ostrich that put
its head in the sand which by the by the
way is also a conspiracy because it
doesn't happen
here is a compilation of
secret societies and their symbols and
signs and who is associated with them
and
let's just run through it
and here you have the illustrations of
the secret handshakes
[Music]
look familiar
and this is the sign of the master of
the second veil
see
purely masonic
you don't pick this stuff up off the
street
[Music]
now this is how it's generally executed
in the public arena
[Music]
so when you see this
or this
you know for certain where it comes from
and who they belong to
look at kramer on the front page of the
privately circulated freemason magazine
officially a mason like fellow brother
tony abbott
and he's doing this
[Music]
now martin
do you see or
are
some so blind that they will not see
there's no one as blind as the one who
doesn't want to see okay so we could
carry on with the kings of the world
and their affiliations to societies
nelson mandela
taboom berkey whoever you want to talk
about they're
all involved in this situation
so shall we have a look at uh some of
the interesting statements
that come out that have codes within
them
[Music]
they're all legit i'm telling you we're
gonna get this
it doesn't matter when
it doesn't matter whether it's in six
minutes
six days or six weeks
we're gonna get it done
so again 666 is of course pure
coincidence and greta tonberg with her
one eye covered there are numerous
pictures
with the same theme
and it's always the same
press organizations that take the
pictures and post them etc etc
are they binding themselves in secret
societies yes and confederating and
confederating
are there religious leaders that belong
to the freemasons
yes yes they are there whether we like
it or not they belong to a confederacy
of evil
and they have no right in god's church
where the law and the testimony is
paramount
but
the fact of the matter is
that we find these people
everywhere and also important to realize
is the causes that they stand for is
part of this
then you must be very weary of the cause
because it's part of the cause of the
confederacy of evil
a power from beneath is working to bring
about the last great scenes and the
drama satan coming as christ and working
with all deceivableness of
unrighteousness in those who are binding
themselves together in secret societies
i've been told
that secret societies have nothing to do
with the bible
now if you if you do a search on the
spirit of prophecy
on secret societies
you will get so many quotes you won't
know how to deal with them
but you you can put into the search
engine secret societies
and you get a whole host and you put
secret society you get a whole host
you put in freemasons one word you get a
whole host you put in three masons two
words you get a whole host you put in
three two words mason leaving the s out
you get another lot so there are
hundreds of statements on this issue and
it has nothing to do with end times
that is so ridiculous
that it boggles the mind that
intelligent people cannot see it and
want to put it into a category
of uh conspiracy theories there's a
reason why you're either denying it or
you're part of it
that's the only solution you're either
denying it because you're ignorant or
you don't want to want to hear it
or maybe you're part of it
much of the matter
i had read related to the echo office
and its management from the beginning
the lord also revealed to me brother
falkhead's connection with the
freemasons
and i plainly stated that unless he
severed every tie that bound him to
these associations he would lose his
soul
is it a serious matter yes you can lose
your soul
have we got an injunction to preach the
word to a fallen world and to say that
babylon is fallen yes is the dragon part
of the babylonian confederacy
did we see in the videos that we just
showed that the kings of the world are
part of this confederacy and part of the
secret societies that many of the
leaders are part of it that the
religious leaders are involved in this
and
that doesn't mean that they all are
but this confederacy has come even into
the church
and unless you sever
and he actually mentions the free masons
by name your connections you will lose
your soul
it is the opposite
of the road to
salvation concerning israel the lord
declared the people shall dwell alone
and shall not be reckoned amongst the
nations
numbers 23 verse 9 to us as well as to
ancient israel these words apply
god's people are to stand alone they are
not to join in any secret society or any
other worldly confederacy
that
includes
the economical councils correct
everything
the observance of the seventh-day
sabbath is to be a sign between them and
god showing that they are his people
they are never to forget
that they are to be a peculiar people
separate from the world inhabit and
practice
through them god will work together from
all nationalities of people for himself
this warning
has to go to the whole world but it also
goes to the church
it's the most important to the church at
this stage yes because the church is the
one the arbiter of the truth correct
and if there are members in the church
or even leaders in the church
that are involved in worldly confederacy
or
god forbid secret societies
then shouldn't they be warned that they
will lose their souls if they continue
in this particular direction
that brings us to another question
question number 10
can we thus put our faith in the rich
and famous and the mighty men of power
and can
the world save us
never
never right
between the two a great golf is fixed
right
so i cannot put my faith in what the
rich and famous are telling me to do
correct
they belong to secret societies they are
being used by the powers that be
to manipulate minds
they will use young bands and dress them
in suits they did exactly the same thing
to the beatles yes when the beatles
first started out they were all in their
little black suits and their little ties
and only later when the people had
become accustomed to this fancy dress
did they change into their
sergeant pepper attire
and bring brought in the whole eastern
religion and the drugs and everything
that goes along with it that is how it
starts
so
nothing has changed under the sun i
cannot listen to the rich and famous
unless of course the rich and famous
come to a realization that
the word is truth and separate
themselves from these societies but then
unfortunately he won't be speaking there
anymore correct now that video that we
showed
was actually one of the rich and famous
that came out
and said that his life is in danger
because he is willing to warn humanity
because he has discovered something
better in the word of god he was part of
that confederacy and correct yes and
then he came out because realized
correct this is not and it's interesting
that those that tell me that i mustn't
speak about these issues
don't know
that i was associated with these things
through my circumstances
and that it is
incomprehensible to me
that they are so blind as to say
it doesn't exist
revelation 6 15 and the kings of the
earth
and the great men and the rich men and
the chief captains and the mighty men
and every bondsman and every free man
hid themselves in the dens and in the
rocks of the mountains it's a very
interesting verse right
it's got the mighty men
it's got the chief captains
it's got the bondsmen
and it's got the free man yeah it's got
actually all of society yeah it even has
the freemasons in there
they will hide themselves
verse 18 says that you may eat the flesh
of kings and the flesh of captains and
the flesh of mighty mens and the flesh
of horses and of them that sit on them
and the flesh of all men both free and
bond both small and great martin
majority no matter how much power is
behind them
is not
in
the right
relationship to the word of god and the
testimony of jesus bottom line that's it
and if we look at those questions so far
where are we in the stream of time are
these things unfolding are these
confederacies being formed do we see
them joining up with those three powers
of babylon
if you cannot see it there's a problem
so what are the responsibilities and
duties of god's people
and this is how important because if you
now realize okay
we are
at the end
we are busy
running towards the finishing line yes
then
everybody's ears should break up now we
should be so attentive
the banner of truth and religious
liberty held a love by the founders of
the gospel church and by god's witnesses
during the centuries that have passed
since
as in this last conflict being committed
to our hands
the responsibility
for this great gift rests with those
whom god has blessed with the knowledge
of his word
we are to receive this word as a supreme
authority
that sets the groundwork right
we are to recognize human government as
an ordinance of divine appointment and
teach obedience to its sacred duty
within its legitimate sphere yeah
but to when its claims conflict with the
claims of god
we must obey god rather than men god's
word must be recognized as above all
human legislation
thus says the lord is not to be set
aside for thus says the church
or thus says the state
the crown of christ is to be lifted
above the diadems of earthly potentates
that's pretty clear that's it so this is
our duty this is our duty within the
church and it's important to start
realizing when
that
church and government are speaking
against god
correct
and sometimes it is necessary to speak
the truth
even if it goes counter to what some
are saying
that brings us to the next question
what happened to the mighty men of the
past ages that oppose the will of god
and what will happen to the final
opposers of his will
i think everybody should realize that
that's a pretty rhetorical question
but let's just have a look at some of
them cain
nimrod
the sirians the empires of daniel 7
and the man of sin
what will be and what was
their
situation and their demise
ii thessalonians 2 3 let no man deceive
you by any means for that day shall not
come except there come a falling away
first
and that man of sin be revealed the son
of perdition martin
have we bent over backwards to try and
reveal what they are doing
who opposes and exalts himself above all
that is called god or that is worshipped
so that he as god sits in the temple of
god showing himself that he is god
what about revelation 19 20 and the
beast was taken
and with him the false prophet that
wrought miracles before him with which
he had deceived them that had received
the mark of the beast and them that
worshipped his image these both were
cast alive into a lack of fire burning
with brimstone
this is a very serious issue definitely
that's
we started off with what will be the
outcome
death
here it's acknowledged eternal death i
cannot dare be associated with them
i might have a peaceful time on earth
but i will have lost eternity
so let me ask some miscellaneous
questions in other words there are so
many questions we've been asking them
all through this presentations
but let's just
put some questions within this question
we're dealing with the kings of the
world and the and the mighty men and the
rulers and the empires
let me ask
were there good kings in israel
in the northern kingdom
no the bible doesn't mention one right
it's a very sad state of affairs
not one
were there good kings in the kingdom of
judah yes
yes
so there were faithful kings
so whether in the majority or in the
minority unfortunately the minority okay
were there good kings that became bad
kings
yes
were they bad kings that became good
kings yes
fortunately yes so this is a battle
between good and evil
were there good kings that became bad
kings that became good kings
yes
solomon right solomon
now this is very interesting because we
can draw a lot of typologies out of this
because we are told
that we are repeating the history of
israel
okay so you're bringing this back to the
church i'm bringing this back to the
church
so let's ask another question then
question number 12 generally speaking
did the majority of these kings tend
towards godliness or towards apostasy
unfortunately apostasy
the majority of the kings tended towards
apostasy
but they were kings of israel weren't
they yes
second chronicles 36 16 says but they
mocked the messengers of god
despised his words and misused his
prophets
until the wrath of the lord arose
against his people till there was
no
remedy
if that's a typology then it's a pretty
sad typology right
ii timothy 3 13 but evil men and
seducers shall wax worse and worse
deceiving and being deceived
nobody needs to be deceived
because we have the bible and the spirit
of prophecy
right it has been foretold on how
to look out
to not being deceived okay
okay that brings us to another question
is the history of redemption written in
the lives of the first three kings of
israel
is that a possible typology
yep okay
could king saul
represent the fall
king david a type of the messiah and the
plan of redemption
and king solomon a type of the church
well we're stretching it now
but
i thought it would be interesting to
speculate on this issue if this can be
brought into harmony with a word in the
testimony then we know we're on the
right track all right
so
maybe you have this interesting typology
here saul is the one
that literally goes into open rebellion
and eventually consults the witch of
endor right
king david has many many faults like all
of us
but he is nevertheless the type of
messiah
and the plan of redemption is
beautifully typified in him
he who fell and who was
raised up again
by the grace of god and then king
solomon as the type of the church let's
look at that one in a little bit more
detail
well 2nd samuel 5 4 says david was 30
years old when he began to reign and he
reigned 40 years
so
david was 30 when he started and there
are so many parallels
messianic parallels where he is a type
of the messiah right
and jesus also started his ministry when
he was 30 years old
first kings chapter 11 verse 42
and the time that solomon reigned in
jerusalem over all israel was 40 years
now solomon is a type of the church
solomon built the temple
then he desecrated the temple
and then finally declared the whole duty
of man representing the final message of
the church to humanity because he said
let us hear the conclusion of the whole
matter
fear god and keep his commandments for
this is the whole duty of man
so he gone through the entire gambit he
started off a good king
and he built the temple i will raise up
this temple said jesus
and the temple is his body and his body
is his church right
then he desecrated the temple
and then he said the whole duty is
the law and the testimony she put it
right again he put it right again
so here's another question
on which portion of solomon's reign
does freemasonry base its belief system
on the good king or the bad king portion
it has to be on the bat portion well
obviously because they're a confederacy
of evil right exactly
solomon put kemos into the temple
they used to sacrifice human beings to
him
we won't go into those saudi details
okay let's have a look at
some freemason sources this is manly
palmer hall
freemason of the 33rd degree a
freemasonry has quoted in his book the
last keys of freemasonry page 63
and it deals with the word solomon
and it's actually an acronym so um on
and he writes he the true mason
realizes that the temple of solomon is
really the temple of the solar man
sol
om
on
the king of the
universe that's lucifer
the sun god
here is a book scarlet and the beast by
john daniels and he says the name sol om
on we know
is the composite name of three sun gods
in roman indian
and egyptian mythology
they school their rituals
on the portion of solomon's reign
that has to do with his state of
apostasy
it's rather sad right
and the enshrine lucifies the true son
of god
another question
question number 15.
where can we expect the battle between
good and evil to rage the strongest
don't answer it let's
let's put it on the screen
jeremiah 17 verse 9 says the heart is
deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked who can know it
so i can assume
that the battle between good and evil
rages in the heart of every individual
that has been born since the time of
adam
yes right
and we all go through it everybody
nobody is free from this nobody nobody
is free from this battle you cannot say
i have arrived and i don't have a battle
we all have this battle
and we have to fight it daily
and the old man of sin that evil one has
to be
bludgeoned to death every single day
so i think we can say the battle between
good and evil rages in the heart right
but then we also hear in revelation 12
17 that the dragon was wroth with the
woman and went to make war with the
remnant of her seed which keep the
commandments of god and have the
testimony of jesus christ that's the
church
now if the dragon is wrath with her
and he makes war with her then can we
expect the battle to rage within her
it has to
this
undoubtedly okay
now we clearly stated
in the last one
that even if you find evil raging within
the church does that make the church
babylon no no
no definitely not right
so we have to be very sure on that issue
so let's read from the great controversy
from the 88 edition page 510 from the
days of adam to our own time our great
enemy has been exercising his power to
oppress and destroy
he is now preparing for his last
campaign against the church
all who seek to follow jesus
will be brought into conflict with this
relentless foe
the more nearly the christian imitates
the divine pattern the more surely will
he make himself a mark of the attacks of
satan
right
all who are actively engaged in the
cause of god
seeking to unveil the deceptions of the
evil one and to present christ before
the people will be able to join in the
testimony of paul
in which he speaks of serving the lord
with all humility of mind with many
tears and temptations
so within the church you can expect a
lot of opposition especially
if you want to unveil the deceptions of
the evil ones
then you can expect
opposition
that's a very serious statement
well it's a very true statement
unfortunately it is a very true
statement
that brings us to the next question
has the apostate church persecuted god's
people throughout the ages and what
should we learn from this
by the apostate church we're referring
to the church of the middle ages right
with to the through the beast system
has it persecuted god's people yes
unrelentlessly
and should we learn from this
if you don't learn from it you will
surely repeat it
that's a very very sad statement
all right historically is this so this
comes from history of the rise and
influence of the spirit of rationalism
in europe volume
2 page 32
that the church of rome has shed more
innocent blood than any other
institution that has ever existed
amongst mankind will be questioned by no
protestant who has a competent knowledge
of history
the memorials indeed of many of her
persecutions are now so scanty
that it is impossible to form a complete
conception of the multitude of her
victims
and it is quite certain that no power of
imagination can adequately realize their
sufferings
that's history
she has persecuted and she's responsible
for the blood of millions upon millions
and millions of god's people
no doubt about it
here's a quote and you can find it on
the web page egw writings
and the following quotes are from the
book facts of faith by christian
edwardson
a persecuting power the little horn was
also to wear out the saints of the most
high daniel 7 25.
that is it was to persecute him till
they were literally worn out has the
papacy fulfilled this part of the
prophecy
in order to do roman catholics no
injustice we shall quote from
unquestioned authorities among them
and since they persecute people for
heresy we must first let them define
what they mean by heresy
in the new catholic dictionary
dictionary published by the universal
knowledge foundation a roman catholic
institution we read
heresy it is choice deciding for oneself
what one shall believe
and practice
according to this definition
anyone who will not blindly submit to
papal authority but will read the bible
deciding for himself what he shall
believe is a heretic
what official stand has the catholic
church taken in regard to such heretics
thus we find stated in the catholic
encyclopedia in the following words
in the bull ad extirpanda
innocent the fourth says
when those
a judged guilty of heresy have been
given up to the civil power by the
bishop or his representative or the
inquisition
the podesta or chief magistrate of the
city shall take them at once and shall
within five days at the most execute the
laws made against them
nor could any doubt remain as to what
civil regulations were meant
for the passages were ordered the
burning of impenitent heretics were
inserted in the papal decretals from the
imperial constitutions
and then it mentions them
so they say
they persecuted
to death
it carries on
therefore said bull
ad
remained thenceforth the fundamental
document of the inquisition
renewed or reinforced by several popes
and mentions alexander and clement and
nicholas and boniface and others
the civil authorities therefore were
enjoyed by the popes under pain of
excommunication to execute the legal
sentences that condemned impenitent
heretics to the stake
it is to be noted that excommunication
itself was no trifle
for if the person excommunicated did not
free himself from excommunication within
a year
he was held by the legislation of that
period to be a heretic and incurred all
the penalties that affected heresy
so they didn't only excommunicate you
throw you out of the church
they killed you
this encyclopedia was printed in
1910 and bears the sanction of the
catholic authorities and of their censor
so that here is up-to-date authority
showing that the romish church sanctions
persecution
they cannot divorce themselves from
their history
all right
let's get a little bit closer
question number 17
is it only the apostate church of the
middle ages that has persecuted god's
children
or did god's people of old persecutes
did the protestant churches persecute
god's children was it only wrong
no did god's people in in the old
testament persecute god's people yes
isn't it interesting that in the time of
ayah who is married to jezebel
and jezebel serves as the type of the
church of the middle ages
persecuted god's people yeah but you
know what's interesting with that story
even
while this persecution was going on
there were
leaders within his court
that hid god's prophets
his preachers in other words in groups
of 50s in
caves
and fed them from the money supply of
the king's table
so god's people were still supported by
the finances of the king
within the church in other words it's
amazing that is very important
to emphasize and while you've got this
blatant apostate leader
the rest of that church
are still supported
correct in that situation
i i don't know how far we should take
that typology but it's interesting
so we can say for sure that it's not
only the church of the middle ages that
persecuted god's children
god's church persecuted god's children
and the protestant churches persecuted
god's children
let's see how god feels about this
in zechariah 7 9
and onwards it says thus speakers the
lord of hosts saying execute true
judgment and show mercy and compassion
every man to his brother
and oppress not the widow nor the
fatherless the stranger nor the poor and
let none of you imagine evil against his
brother in your heart
but they refused to hearken
and pulled away the shoulder and stopped
their ears that they should not hear
yea they made the hearts of an adamant
stone
lest they should hear the law
and the words which the lord of hosts
has sent any spirit by the former
prophets therefore came a great wrath
from the lord of hosts can we see we
have the same issue
they turned their ear from the law
and the words in other words the law and
the testimony
therefore it came to pass that he cried
and they would not hear so they cried
and i would not hear
says the lord of hosts
how long halty between two opinions
testimonies for the church volume three
if the lord be god follow him but if
baal then follow him and the people
answered him not a word
not one of that vast assembly dead utter
one word for god and show his loyalty to
to jehovah
so how did the situation come about
because this is really a typological
story
of how the prophets of baal
with in and the prophets of ashtoreth
within the church will eventually
come to their demise
and it's interesting that the elijah
message has a lot to do with it
testimonies to the church volume three
what astonishing deception and fearful
blindness
had like a dark cloud covered israel
this blindness and apostasy had not
closed about them suddenly
it had come upon them gradually
as they had not heeded the word of
reproof and warning which the lord had
sent to them because of their pride and
their sins
and now in this fearful crisis in the
presence of the idolatrous priests and
apostate king
they remained neutral
if god abhors one sin above another of
which his people are guilty it is doing
nothing
in case of an emergency
indifference and neutrality in a
religious crisis
is regarded of god as a grievous crime
and equal to the very worst type of
hostility against god
so we cannot remain neutral you have to
take a stand and you cannot remain
silent
you're either with the prophets of power
or you're with god's people
and this was pertaining to god's church
correct
let's have a look at some historic
sources and just make sure
about this persecution issue
this comes from courses
lumenlearning.com
and it talks about persecution roman
catholics and protestants alike
persecuted the anabaptists
resorting to torture and execution in
attempts to curb the growth of the
movement
the protestants and the swingly were the
first to persecute the anabaptists with
felix months becoming the first martyr
in 1527.
on may 20 1527 roman catholic
authorities executed michael sattler
king ferdinand declared drowning
called the third baptism the best
antidote to anabaptism
so did the kings of the world
and the church persecute yes and we're
dealing with protestant churches and
catholic churches the tudor regime
even the protestant monarchs edward the
sixth of england and elizabeth the first
of england
persecuted anabaptists
as they were deemed too radical and
therefore a danger to religious
stability
the persecution of anabaptists was
condoned by ancient laws of theodosius
the first and justinian the first that
were passed against the donatists which
decreed the death penalty for any who
practiced re-baptism
martha's mirror by tillman
describes the persecution and execution
of thousands of anabaptists in various
parts of europe between 1525 and 1660.
continuing persecutions in europe was
largely responsible for the mass
emigration to north america by amish
hutterites and mennonites
so persecution has been the name of the
game throughout the centuries
if you don't agree
then you are done away with yeah doesn't
matter if it's
papal
or protestant now
irrespective of
the issues surrounding the anabaptists
whether they had fanatical views or not
the fact of the matter is why they were
persecuted is because of adult baptism
is it biblical yes so were they actually
sentenced to death because they believed
the word yes
okay
what about the amish and the mennonites
irrespective of what their other views
are they were persecuted because they
came into conflict with the church
even though many of their doctrines were
biblical yeah
in fact james madison
born in port conway virginia in the
united states
was one of the presidents
of the united states said the purpose of
separation of church and state is to
keep forever from these shores the
ceaseless strife that has soaked the
soil of europe in
blood for centuries
so
this is a war that has been raging for a
long long time
i'm almost afraid to ask the next
question
but before we get there let's read one
more statement in every generation god
has sent his servants to rebuke sin both
in the world
and
in the church
but the people desire smooth things
spoken to them and the pure unvarnished
truth is not acceptable many reformers
in entering upon their work determined
to exercise great prudence in attacking
the sins of the church
and the nation
they hope by example of a pure christian
life to lead the people back to the
doctrines of the bible
but the spirit of god came upon them as
they came upon elijah
and they could not refrain from
preaching the plain utterances of the
bible doctrines which they had been
reluctant to present
they were impelled to zealously declare
the truth and the danger which
threatened souls
the words which the lord gave them they
uttered fearless of consequences and the
people were compelled to hear the
warning
so this is the situation that we are in
today
we need
to say
what god impresses upon our minds
even if it brings us into conflict right
like we've read in an early the earlier
statement
god abhors neutrality in the time of
crisis correct
all right this is the question that i'm
almost afraid to ask
has the remnant church always dealt
kindly with god's children
has it dealt kindly with god's prophets
and his messengers through the ages
and will the remnant possibly even
persecute god's children in the end
now when i talk about the remnant i'm
talking about the church as a whole
but
of course there are all kinds of fish
within this church
and we cannot call the church babylon
even though some of the fish might not
actually belong into the gospel net
how do we know that they don't belong
into the gospel nest because they don't
believe the bible and the spirit of
prophecy right that's the criterium
so let us be very careful
and not turn our weapons against the
church
militant
but the fact of the matter is they
haven't always dealt kindly with god's
children
nor they dealt kindly with god's
prophets
it's important to
we want to uplift the church we want to
get this church because it has to take
the message out to the world to the fi
this is the final church
absolutely and it it is the final
message of warning it is the apple of
its eye
and if something needs to take place to
wake it up exactly
then it has to be said right
so let's ask ourselves
how did
the church
that means members in the church and
leaders in the church how did they treat
james white
read testimonies to the church volume 1.
they treated him like the early church
treated paul yeah
and sent him to an early grave
right yeah
how did they treat
ellen white they even
banned her to australia
and they wrote the most horrendous
things against her and she met with so
much coldness
that she was so perplexed at times
that uh
her pen could hardly pin the anguish
right
so
when james white and ellen white
preached
to the church particularly about their
faults
their reception wasn't exactly rosy no
right can we say that
all right
how did they treat hannah moore
that's a very sad story it's a very sad
story right
that she had to die
separated from those that she felt an
affiliation to long to be with long to
be with them letters were written even
by pastors of other denominations
and
it's just unbelievable how they treated
hannah moore how did they treat johnson
wagner
not very
kindly not very kindly right
so whenever somebody got up and spoke
the truth
like james white or
alan white
then
they
were faced with a fair amount of wrath
and jones and wagner
well
they were driven to the point where they
virtually gave up right
how did they treat b.g wilkinson
well not very differently not very
differently
bj wilkinson i mean if you read his his
writings
truth triumphant yeah what a magnificent
book right
our authorized version vindicated he was
actually one of the first to write on
this issue he actually set the gold
standard yes
and started this debate and you know
what i'm so proud that this debate
started within this remnant denomination
where else could it start
god used ellen white god used jones and
wagner and i believe god used bg
wilkinson
and the spirit of prophecy bears out
what he did
but they treated him very unkindly
and in fact it is only after his death
that his answers to objections was
published
and to this day the war is raging about
what he wrote right
how did they treat gerard hazel
i met gareth hazel personally
and i very fondly remember
that we went and sat under a tree
at our college in south africa
and there we sat and chatted
and
we had such a good conversation that he
got his
his next appointment so we had to rush
because he was late for that
but then he came to my home and
we had lunch together and we chatted
some more
and later on i heard the very sad story
about how he was often treated
by one of his very very close associates
firsthand not secondhand
but i want to say if it weren't for
gareth hazel
i don't know whether our theology would
be
so beautifully packaged as it is
and how do they treat some of our modern
day medical missionaries and evangelists
you know what it is with much sadness
that i sometimes see how they treat
these people now let's be fair
some of our
modern day medical missionaries and
evangelists you know might not always
have it absolutely spot on
but they sacrifice time convenience
family
spend time away from home
sleep on floors sometimes
i mean they accused them of money
grabbing their cues they accused me of
that too
you've been at the other end to my face
they accused me of doing this for money
and the irony is
they accused me of doing it for money
when i just sold my car and my wife had
to walk so that i could go and continue
the work but
they did the same to ellen white
what about some of our medical
missionary workers that spend their
lives
bringing the message of salvation
through
television stations
risking their lives taking medication to
people spending times in jail
for the sake of the gospel it's so easy
modern
when you sit at a at a desk
in some fancy office
to run these people down even if they
even if they
make a mistake here or there
but when you study their characters and
you look at their zeal i look at some of
the medical people
that work under such difficult
circumstances to bring alternative
healing methods to the people how they
are treated sometimes
and how they are ostracized and run down
it is a very very sad state of affairs
so what can we expect in the future
2 timothy 3 verse 12 says yea and all
that will live godly in christ jesus
shall suffer persecution
but i want to say to our missionaries
i want to say to our evangelists
i want to say to our people that work in
the jungles
that take the health message to
the poor and those that cannot afford to
be helped
i want to say to them don't lose courage
it happened in the past to the prophets
of god how was elijah treated
no different no different
look at how ellen white was treated look
at how hannah moore was treated look at
how johnson wagner was treated look at
how wilkinson was treated how hassle was
treated
and
should we expect less
but there are so many that appreciate it
there are so many that stand for truth
and righteousness within this church
this is god's church
and even if there are
people
that will want to persecute those that
preach the message
there are many many more that love the
truth
and their lights will shine brightly
when the time comes
but sadly we are told in selected
messages that we have far more to fear
from within than from without
the hindrances to strength and success
are far greater from the church itself
than from the world
unbelievers have a right to expect
that those who profess to be keeping the
commandments of god in the faith of
jesus will do more than any other class
to promote and honor
by their consistent lives by their godly
example and their active influence the
cause which they represent
but i often have the professed advocates
of the truth prove the greatest obstacle
to its advancement
this is not
us speaking no this is the spirit of
prophecy god
god speaking through the spirit of
prophecy to tell the church
be careful
the unbelief indulged the doubts
expressed
the darkness cherished
encouraged the presence of evil angels
and opened the way for the
accomplishment of satan's devices
irrespective
this is the apple of his eye the only
object on which he pours out his supreme
regard
the work which the church has failed to
do in a time of peace and prosperity she
will have to do in a terrible crisis
and the most discouraging forbidding
circumstances the warnings that the
worldly conformity has silenced
or withheld
must be given under the fiercest
opposition from the enemies of the faith
button if you in these days stand up
and deliver a message on behalf
of the three angels messages you will
experience opposition
not only from without but also from
within
and at that time the superficial
conservative class whose influence has
steadily the progress of the
work will renounce the faith
and take their stand with their vowed
enemies towards whom their sympathies
have long been tending
these apostates will then manifest the
most bitter enmity doing all in their
power to oppress them align their former
brethren and to excite indignation
against them
let me put it bluntly
they are not really of the church no
they're of the world they're in the
church
but they're not of the church
and they will become the most bitterest
enemies of those who preach the three
angels messages
and their influence has been increasing
but they will renounce the faith they
will take their stand with the world to
whom their sympathies have been
tending for a long long time already
and this must encourage people in the
church
to not want to leave the church
absolutely you don't want to leave it
now you stand you stand i've always said
put superglue yes on your chair and sit
on it
so don't leave this church
no
let's do what god expects us to do let's
lift up our voices like a trumpet
this day is just before us the members
of the church will individually be
tested and proved they will be placed in
circumstances where they will be forced
to bear witness for the truth
if you don't do it willingly you're
going to be forced
many will be called to speak before
councils and in courts of justice
perhaps separately and alone
the experience which would have helped
them in this emergency they have
neglected to obtain
and their souls are burdened with
remorse for wasted opportunities and
neglected
privileges if you preach this message
and you get the opposition
it actually gives you some practice for
what is coming
in our previous one we did mention the
one where she dreamt about the catholic
procession that night i dreamed that i
was in battle creek
now we're not going to read it again but
the fact of the matter is
that
there was this concept of catholic
ideology within the church
among some
and
we also showed that the world has no
right to doubt true christianity because
they are unworthy members of the church
nor should christians become
disheartened because of these false
brethren
and then she mentioned simon magus and
all of those that were involved even
judas
so
that's not a reason to leave the church
correct
the question is of the church or of the
world we looked at that as well and we
saw
that those that are of the world even
though they are in the church can become
the most bitter enemies of their former
brethren and we also saw that they
become a beacon for you not to carry on
correct
and that they become efficient agents
when you come before the courts
so we can expect some people
even from within the church to turn
against the message
but let's have a word of caution
matthew 7 verse 1 judge not
that ye be not judged
luke 6 37 judge not
and ye shall not be judged condemn not
and ye shall not be condemned forgive
and ye shall be forgiven
or john 7 24 judge not according to the
appearance but judge righteous judgments
there are many of the church that i
might be inclined to consider as enemies
of the truth right
but i'm not supposed to judge
i may not judge the person
but i can't judge the deed right yes
so
judge not the man but rebuke the deed
isaiah tells us cry loud spare not lift
up your voice like a trumpet
show my people their transgression in
the house of jacob their sins
because some believe that you shouldn't
say anything about these issues
so we don't know who we are dealing with
and this is the example that i always
use are we dealing with aaron are we
dealing with caiaphas
we must leave that for god to decide
because if i had to judge from
appearances
i would definitely condemn
aaron
who created the golden calf and told
them to dance around the golden cough
and i would say well caiaphas is a
health-reforming
law keeping individual
and i wouldn't know until he crucified
the lord right correct
so do they oppose the message of warning
and go along with the popular stream out
of fear for their position or fear of
radical as did aaron
will they go with the popular stream for
fear of their lives or because of
personal conviction i don't know
and are they infiltrators or just
deceived
let's leave that to god
revelation 22 20 says he which testifies
these things surely i come quickly amen
even so come
lord jesus
so modern
our christians have taken us through the
sweep
of our prophetic understanding
even to the point of expecting great
opposition from within
but that doesn't make this church
babylon
and this church is going through to the
kingdom
and the true
stars will shine
brightly
when the darkness increases so may god
in his mercy
grant us the courage to speak when we
have to
and
the brotherly love
that binds us
to our brothers and sisters in christ
let us not judge them as human beings
but let the truth be spoken
let's pray
heavenly father
how do we deal with this issue
so many people are looking
and saying that they do not agree with
this that and the other
let us preach the three angels messages
together let us warn against the mark of
the beast that is coming let us find
solidarity
in the three angels messages because we
are allowed to have nothing else to
occupy our minds
thank you that we can be part of a
movement
that is still
lifting its voice in defense of the word
and the testimony of jesus christ
thank you in jesus name amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe
click here
when the bell appears
click again to get notifications
to watch the next video
click here
thank you